did the producers of Marvel's Deadpool 3
conspire to rig the 2023 2024 NFL season
and the Super Bowl using Taylor Swift
and Travis Kelce welcome back to New
rockstars I'm Eric Boss and we have to
talk about what might be the biggest
media story of the past year how the
biggest names of Hollywood music and
sports teamed up in a brilliant
marketing ploy to boost NFL ratings grow
Taylor Swift start them to even higher
Heights and most importantly for viewers
of this channel rescue the Marvel
Cinematic Universe our Focus here on the
new Rockstar channel is to analyze films
and break down their marketing
strategies not really talk about sports
or music or celebrity gossip but with
Kansas City going to the Super Bowl on
February 11th the same day we're
expecting to get our first trailer for
Marvel's Deadpool 3 a film rumor to
feature Taylor Swift herself after
Taylor began dating Chief's tight end
Travis Kelce and appeared at an October
1st game with the Stars and director of
Deadpool 3 we must wait Wilson into
unfamiliar Waters to explain how Ryan
Reynolds cleverly brokered a marketing
plan to bail out Disney's Marvel Studios
using the combined fandoms of the NFL
and Taylor Swift so in this video I will
investigate the timeline and break down
this conspiracy in Three Steps step one
Hollywood step two Taylor Swift and step
three the NFL and I will demonstrate how
the Elites from each of these worlds
joined forces to make this the
entertainment media narrative that no
one can avoid and yes this story may
have been something that has been so
annoying to you but to quote the Ancient
One this isn't about you this is about
making Deadpool 3 a guaranteed billion
dooll event and to get there they need
not just us to see this movie but they
need our sports-loving brothers and
uncles and our tailor loving sisters and
nieces and uncles because you know they
love her too and to any swifties
watching this video I have nothing but
support for what Taylor is doing here I
propose to my wife while playing lover
her in 2021 I posted a Twitter Thread
about all two Well's connections to the
Spider-Man films and this is a
friendship bracelet that my niece Marley
gave me after we went to see the ays
movie she she says I'm cardigan I don't
know what that means but I love it and
to see if I'm right about this Taylor
Swift and Deadpool 3 Conspiracy Theory
come hang out with us at our live show
in Los Angeles the week after the Super
Bowl February 15th at brain dead Studios
we're going to have a lot of fun ticket
Link in the description it is so easy to
fall into a rut with food but it's also
so boring my problem is that if it's
left up to me I'll eat the same boring
stuff every single day like Zack hudon
which is exactly why I'm thrilled when
instead of having to figure it out on my
own cook Unity can do it for me cook
Unity is the first chef 2 consumer
platform that delivers freshly prepared
pre-selected meals right to your door
weekly cook Unity is basically a
pipeline from your home to dozens of
talented chefs that cook delicious
inventive meals fresh everyday and
Regional micro kitchens not Warehouse
production facilities and the meals they
make are updated weekly so you can't get
bored you can pick from whopping 350
plus meals each week based on your
dietary needs including vegetarian
pescatarian and keto you know that's me
what kind of do you like or just I don't
know give me chicken I won't forget
which could be the Esther Choice
Teriyaki roasted salmon or if you're
more in the mood for beef you could have
a Stacy bearing grilled Asian hanger
steak with charred broccolini variety is
the spice of life and with cook Unity
you can live a spicy life cook Unity is
roster of Allstar chefs include Food
Network alums James Beard award winners
and acclaimed restaurant turs balancing
flavor and nutrition in the Creations
there is seemingly endless variety of
meals to choose from the subscription is
super flexible you can pause skip weeks
or cancel at any time and it's super
easy do go to cook unity.com enrock
stars50 or click the link in the
description and use my code nrock
stars50 to get 50% off your first order
of cookunity meals to try them out for
yourself okay so how did Deadpool rig
the Super Bowl step one Hollywood let's
rewind the clock to June 2023 Deadpool 3
director sha Levy was rushing to get as
much of Deadpool 3 shot as possible with
stars Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman for
the looming sag after strike would force
production to shut down on June 13th
Deadpool 3 was actually moved up from a
fall release of November 8 2024 to an
early summer release of May 3rd 2024 and
this I think has been the only time in
recent years we have heard of a movie
being moved up by that much most of the
time it's like delayed to like 3 years
from now this was moved up so the
production Rush was so intense that the
typical security measures taken for
Marvel Studios Productions were
completely bypassed and as a result a
slew of spoilery set photos leaked
throughout the summer to get ahead of
this on July 10th Ryan Reynolds and Hugh
Jackman shared the first high-res image
of Jack in in his highly anticipated new
yellow and blue Wolverine suits for this
movie but the important thing to know
about the Deadpool films is that Ryan
Reynolds has always taken the lead on
the marketing himself in ways few other
Blockbuster franchises do it was Ryan
Reynold's social media campaign that
made the 2016 Deadpool reboot possible
Deadpool 3 was announced to the public
as a team up with Hugh Jackman Wolverine
on September 28th 2022 not by Marvel
Studios at San Diego Comic-Con or at d23
but by Ryan Reynolds himself on his
personal YouTube account that was really
weird so back to the summer 2023 4 days
after that Wolverine photo came out on
July 14th sag aftera went on strike and
production for all movies including
Deadpool 3 shut down this strike would
not be resolved until November 9th and
on that same day Marvel cryptically
announced a new release date for
Deadpool 3 July 26th 2024 and that July
release weekend was no coincidence in
summer 2023 the weekend of July 21st was
barbin Heimer weekend it led Barbie to
be a billion dollar hit it led
Oppenheimer to reach nearly a billion
dollars and most likely sweep the Oscars
it was a very good summer for Warner
Brothers who released Barbie and
Universal who released Oppenheimer but
not for Disney despite a modest hit with
Guardians of the Galaxy volume 3 in May
Disney's other summer releases including
Pixar's Elemental Lucas Films Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny and the
Haunted Mansion performed below
expectations on Disney plus Marvel's
secret invasion was panned as the worst
ever MCU title Marvel 's upcoming fall
releasee the Marvel's was tracking to
underperform in the court case of
Marvel's arch villain actor Jonathan
Majors was looming so Marvel and Disney
desperately needed a hit that they could
Point shareholders to and at the end of
summer 2023 every Studio saw Barbie's
success that summer and wondered how do
we do this every summer and heading into
2024 there are probably three movies
that have the best chance of making a
billion dollar Despicable Me four
Deadpool 3 and wicked Joker 2 might have
a chance and maybe there's some other
long shot candidate but those three have
the best chance when it comes to Wicked
there have been rumors of onset drama
with Ariana Grande's affair with co-star
Ethan Slater breaking of his marriage
and with Deadpool 3 it seems like the
direction is to go full eras in both
cases 2024 Hollywood is steering into
the Goss and no one deals in Goss and
tea and cryptic Easter eggs quite like
Tes Swift so step two Taylor Swift
Taylor Swift was times 20123 person of
the year and it was mostly for her
insanely successful AAS tour the Aras
tour launched on March 17th 2023 in
Glendale Arizona and by June it was the
tour everyone was trying to get a ticket
to on June 2nd Taylor extended the tour
to Latin America and then later on in
that month Taylor extended the tour to
Asia and on June 21st she announced
three dates in Tokyo February 8th 9th
and 10th that you may note is Super Bowl
weekend but the fact that this
announcement came in June is important
on July 8th Travis Kelce tight end for
the Kansas City Chiefs attended Taylor's
concert at Kansas City's Arrowhead
Stadium this is his home field and
Taylor actually used used the chief's
locker room as her dressing room and
Taylor's cousins would take selfies not
realizing that they'd be right in front
of Kelsey's locker and a few weeks later
on July 26th Travis Kelce talks about
this on the new heights podcast speaking
of Taylor Swift I know you went to the
Taylor Swift concert how was it yeah
well I was disappointed that uh she
doesn't talk before or after her shows
because she has to save her voice for
the 44 songs that she sings so I was a
little butt hurt I didn't get to hand
her uh one of the bracelets I made for
her you made her a bracelet yeah if
you're if you're up on Taylor Swift
concerts there are frencher bracelets
and I received a bunch of them being
there but I wanted to give Taylor Swift
one with my number on it all right now
oo your number is in 87 or your phone
number you know which one um so she that
she doesn't meet anybody and she doesn't
or at least she didn't want to meet me
so I um I took a personal but was an
unbelievable show and
honestly showed out I've only seen
Arrowhead filled like that for Chiefs
games without much excitement and um
yeah everybody was dressed in pink and
purple going crazy for it was wild it
was a wild show well she she probably
just hasn't gotten over the Super Bowl
yet she's a big Eagles fan so maybe she
just made something up and just didn't
want to talk to you damn it ah so we
later learned in a November 20th Wall
Street Journal interview with Travis
Kelce that someone in Swift's Camp
brought Kelsey's public crush on her to
Taylor's attention Kelsey said quote I
had somebody playing Cupid and
throughout these interviews they have
never mentioned who that mystery Cupid
was Kelsey said that Taylor texted him
shortly after the new heights podcast
and that the relationship Grew From
There Taylor Swift told time on December
6th after they announced that she was
person of the year that when she heard
Kelsey on the podcast on July 26th she
thought it was quote metal as hell and
that they started hanging out right
after that so throughout the weeks of
August in September 2023 rumors started
to swirl and on September 14th Kelsey
would appear in an interview with NFL
plus and he gets asked about Taylor
Swift by Andrew ccil I said what I said
and I meant what I said when I said it
you shot your shot huh man and you know
what it is what it is I'm not going to
talk about my personal life I know what
you writers want to hear and you want to
hear more about that and I'm not going
to give you anything has she reached out
huh has she reached out and that's going
to wrap it up here with NFL oh wait wait
wait wait at this point the NFL notices
that references to Taylor Swift boost
engagement on their social posts so on
September 17th during the Chiefs Jaguars
game the NFL announcer Ian Eagles says
Chelsea finds a blank space and then
during the pregame commentary NFL
Network's Rich Eisen Works in as many
tailor lyrics as he can well even though
that bone bruise and the injury one
would think is delicate he's been able
to shake it off I should have known that
all too well that you would not know
well I mean you saw it on Thursday night
when Travis Kelce wasn't in there it
left a blank space uh but I think he
returns today and proves to be the
anti-hero I'm with you I've never never
out of style putting on the Lone Wolf
hat all right there are the Chiefs oh
Kelsey coming out all AUST is over now
September and the Travis Kelce would
respond to this post on social media
saying well played Rich well played the
following week Travis Kelce would
continue to tease the relationship on
the Pat McAfee show while his brother
Jason Kelce confirms that the two are
dating on sports radio 94 wiip this
brings us to September 24th when Travis
Kelce and Taylor Swift first appear
publicly together at the Chiefs Bears
game Swift sat in the Kelce family Suite
with Travis's Mom Donna and she left
this game holding hands with Travis
passing sports reporter Jarrett p
how you so now it was public and
official and the networks went crazy
they went all in on Taylor Swift on
September 29th NBC used Welcome to New
York in a TV spot for the upcoming
Chiefs Prime Time game against the New
York Jets and this is the October 1st
game where our paths cross Taylor Swift
arrives to MetLife Stadium to watch the
game and she is joined by her longtime
friend Blake Lively and Blake Lively's
husband Ryan Reynolds as well as his
Deadpool 3 crew Direct Sean Levy and
co-star Hugh Jackman this was the first
time Taylor would appear at a game in
prime time and everyone in that Suite
knew that all eyes would be on them so
Taylor Swift and Blake Lively had been
friends since 2015 and Lively and
Reynolds had attended a number of Swift
social events over the years but Sean
Levy and Hugh Jackman joining them at
the game would leave movie Watchers to
speculate that Taylor Swift could cameo
in the Deadpool 3 film with some
theorizing that she could play the pop
singer mutant dazzler or maybe she could
just appear as herself now remember we
never learned who that Miss Myster Cupid
was who showed Taylor that interview on
the new heights podcast could that have
been a podcast watched by Ryan Reynolds
who then told Blake Lively about it that
Blake Lively brought it to Taylor's
attention that's just me speculating we
do not know but for the next several
weeks Watchers of NFL games would notice
sometimes to their annoyance cameras is
frequently cut into Taylor Swift
reacting in the box but you know showing
celebrities and VIPs in the boxes is
just something that NFL games always do
because this is a media event it's
designed to sell advertising bols Taylor
Swift and Travis Kelce would appear in
the October 14th season premiere of
Saturday live and they attended the
Afterparty and then Taylor Swift's
November 11th show in Brena ciris Travis
Kelce joined her and in the closing song
Karma Taylor changed the lyrics from
karma is the guy in the screen coming
straight home to me to this karma is the
guy on
the and that brings us to this past week
when Deadpool 3 has wrapped production
and the Chiefs beat the Baltimore Ravens
to win the AFC Championship setting up a
Super Bowl matchup on February 11th
between the Kansas City Chiefs and the
San Francisco 49ers when the Chiefs won
Taylor celebrated with with Travis skel
on the field wearing a TNT Taylor and
Travis friendship bracelet bringing
their courtship full circle now fans
have noted that Taylor Swift will be
performing in Tokyo the weekend of the
Super Bowl doing a concert on the night
of Saturday February 10th could she make
it back in time for the Super Bowl game
in Las Vegas on Sunday February 11th
well Tokyo is 17 hours ahead of Las
Vegas so when Taylor flies eastbound
from Tokyo she would cross the
International Date Line and effectively
go back in time and gain a day so
Taylor's Tokyo concert starts at 6:00
p.m. on Saturday lasts about 4 or 5
hours and then if she were to depart
Tokyo in her private jet it would be
like a 13-hour flight Eastbound and she
would land in Las Vegas at 8:00 p.m. Las
Vegas time on Saturday night which would
give her enough time to sleep off some
jet lag and be there for a 4:30 p.m.
kickoff time Las Vegas time don't go by
the clocks in the casinos Taylor because
they don't exist and for all you Venom
heads following this the amount of time
it would take Riot to swim across the
Pacific Ocean is 6 months now while
Taylor can make this journey with enough
time to be there for the game it is
clear that the Tokyo dates and the date
of the Super Bowl were just completely
unrelated folks Taylor set those dates
in June before Travis Kelce saw her in
her show in July and before they started
talking at the end of July but the third
leg of this conspiracy is the entity I
know the least about but it is the
organization most criticized for shady
Behavior so had his Deadpool rig the
Super Bowl step three the NFL so after
winning the Super Bowl last year the
Kansas City Chiefs win into a summer
2023 with what many considered to be the
weakest lineup of their recent dominant
era quarterback Patrick Mahomes was
going into a season with really no good
receiver other than Travis Kelce the
season opener between the Chiefs and the
Lions which Detroit won made Kansas City
look pretty weak but they did pretty
well throughout the season and going
into the postseason Kansas City was like
third or fourth seed and the Baltimore
Ravens are really the favorites to win
the AFC Tommy was hoping the Buffalo
Bills would break through I was hoping
my hometown Jacksonville Jaguars would
but you know all of us are sad now but I
just bring up Kansas City's prospects at
the beginning of the year because it's
just not likely that anyone would have
looked at this Kansas City Chiefs in
summer 2023 and thought this is our
likeliest AFC Super Bowl contender let's
partner the biggest pop star with the
tight end and Market the crap out of
this while paying some referees to throw
a few calls Kansas City's way to make
sure this goes all the way to Vegas and
Taylor can give Travis Kelce a jet lag
smooch on the field I'll say it once and
I'll say it again never confuse
incompetence with conspiracy that said
let's spend a second in conspiracy
Corner brought to you by new rockstars
producer John Costa last year Super Bowl
57 ended with a very controversial call
that Eagles fans claim handed the Chiefs
the win this would be before Taylor but
still that October 1st Prime Time game
with Taylor Swift and Brian Reynolds H
Jackman and Sean Levy in attendance
ended with two controversial calls one
pass interference called incorrectly one
ridiculous holding penalty on December
10th the chiefs were driving to beat the
Buffalo builds and what would have been
a game-winning touchdown but were called
offsides on wide receiver cadarius Tony
go Gator but while most agreed with the
call Chiefs quarterback Mahomes
complained after the game that normally
the referees warn them before the snap
if they're not aligned to that the
game's referee team said that no warning
was required especially if the receiver
was so far offside that they were
blocking their view of the ball and that
they would have given a warning if it it
were close but not if it were that
Beyond a warning and on the January 1st
game between the Detroit Lions and the
Dallas Cowboys Revere Brad Allen
controversially overturned what would
have been a game-winning two-point
conversion by Detroit because he said
left tackled Taylor Decker didn't report
as an eligible receiver though videos
showed that he totally did but the refs
said that tackle Dan Skipper reported
this didn't really affect Kansas City's
prospects but some fans point to this as
evidence of rigging throughout the NFL
at large ultimately America just did not
want a Chiefs 49ers Super Bowl they
wanted like a Bill's Lions matchup or a
Ravens Lions matchup or jaguars lions
matchup I say this as someone who
currently lives in San Francisco and
will probably get jumped on the street
after seeing this really the biggest sin
of the NFL in the networks and all of
this has been the way their coverage has
put Taylor Swift in the spotlight the
New York Times did a fascinating
analysis of the amount of screen time by
the second that Taylor Swift appeared in
each of her recent game appearances each
of these games mind you were about 3 and
1/2 to 4 hours of Total broadcast so
we're just talking about the few seconds
that we've seen Taylor Swift and each of
these December 25th Chiefs versus
Raiders we got three Taylor cutaways 14
seconds total of Taylor December 31st
Chiefs versus Bengals three cutaways 12
seconds total of Taylor January 13th
Chiefs versus Dolphins five cutaways 16
seconds total of Taylor January 21st
Chiefs versus Bills five cutaways 21
seconds total of Taylor January 28th
Chiefs versus Ravens the AFC
Championship four cutaways 32 seconds
total of Taylor and yes while that's not
a whole lot you are seeing a slight
increase over that time these numbers
are certainly telling but they do not
tell the complete story because you know
For Better or Worse viewers don't see
the world statistically they see it
anecdotally and anecdotally the networks
are playing directly into this
expectation in that January 28th game
against the Ravens when Pat Mahomes
threw a touchdown to Travis Kelce to
give the Chiefs an early lead we see
Travis Kelce scoring spiking the ball
and then immediately we cut to Taylor
Swift in the Box normally we would see
like a replay of the play in slow motion
from a different angle or like more
shots of the players celebrating or the
coaches reacting or just general fans in
the stands instead CBS decided to cut to
Taylor Swift first and this was after
months of the networks in the league
being called out for doing exactly this
CBS is like we don't care and yes you
could say Taylor Swift is a mega star
who knows the power of her attendance at
any event but the forces exploiting this
moment go far beyond Taylor Swift I mean
now we're even seeing political
conspiracies trying to tie this to the
2024 election that's not what this is
about it wasn't Joe Biden or Nikki Haley
or Donald Trump in the box with Taylor
at the first Prime Time game on October
1st it was the stars and director of a
Hollywood movie Deadpool 3 and that's
why I am so focused on Deadpool 3's
involvement in this but the truth is my
friends Travis Kelce attending Taylor
Swift's July 8th concert and forming a
crush on her was probably just a random
sincere thing and Taylor just saw this
podcast and was like sure it was really
the rest of the media that seized on
this opportunity the NFL in the networks
referencing Taylor Swift's music and I
think Ryan Reynolds and what is expected
to be the biggest trailer on Super Bowl
Sunday day Deadpool 3 I only say this
because that mystery cupid in Taylor
Swiss orbit who showed her that Travis
Kelce interview on New Heights podcast
could have been BL Lively or Ryan
Reynolds but I don't think I'll ever
find proof that it was them who did that
but I am staying here if Taylor Swift
shows up in that Super Bowl trailer as
many are expecting her to for all the
media forces cashing and on Taylor and
Travis mission accomplished well done
think about it if you are Ryan Reynolds
and the whole marketing for your
Deadpool MCU arrival the Advent of the
X-Men in the MCU is largely on your
shoulders you're in the driver's seat
and you're in a position to save the
biggest movie franchise of all time and
you've had time now to rest strategize
your movie due to a labor strike and
Marvel has cleared their 2024 calendar
for your movie and your wife's friend
Taylor Swift is having the biggest
summer of her life now with an NFL star
trying to give her a friendship bracelet
and now you see an opening on Super Bowl
Sunday for your movie to dominate the
year yeah that is a no-brainer Ryan
Reynolds would be stupid not to make
this call look I think it's clear
Deadpool 3 can make a billion dollars
without Taylor Swift and it's not like
every Swifty would line up to see an
R-rated Deadpool movie but the way that
Toby McGuire and Andrew Garfield made
Spider-Man no way home unmissable Taylor
Swift just brings an extra dimension of
star power that no one can deny after
having Harry Styles Cameo and the
eternals post credit scene leaked and
spoiled Marvel's got to know that they
got to come right out with these cameos
and put a star that big in the trailer
so I don't know if anyone rigged the
Super Bowl but I do believe that as
usual many media figures are trying to
hijack it and Ryan Reynolds and Deadpool
3 may have found their way in with
Taylor Swift also if you're loving this
moment that we're in and you want to
support what we're doing here at new
rockstars the best way to support us is
by grabbing one of these eras inspired
Multiverse tour Deadpool shirts I can't
wait to get one for myself I'm going to
be wearing one Super Bowl Sunday these
are available in our merch store nerd
riot. shop give this video a like And
subscribe to new rock stars I'm Eric
Boss thanks for watching and I'll see
you next time
bye
[Music]
la